miss me
[Laughter]
anymore
[Music]
foreign
whatever
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
meaning
and welcome back to the riddles podcast
today we're joined again with our
brother Ibrahim X formerly known as Lord
bear
and
he's looking good man about it
just to get started um one of the
biggest things that's going around
nowadays is the whole item 22 situation
with him and his his wife and you know
what he did which I don't want to you
know say it because I think everyone
knows about one year opinion on it
yeah I have an interesting take on it
and it's actually going to be something
I don't think people have considered
because I got really at you know have
you seen so I'll ask you this question
do you know the whole Afghani Kardashian
things that's been going on yeah yeah
where did you where did you hear about
that let's talk
how did you from from where sorry on
tick tock on Tick Tock see everyone I've
spoke to said that the only way they
found out about it was from content
creators reposting it and with the whole
Adam 22 thing again the only way I heard
about that was from people making
clickbait thumbnails and clickbait
titles reviews and I always say and I
don't like it at all because you're
marketing it imagine if like these bit
and I don't Point names out I'm not
trying to do that it's more the behavior
I don't like and people can hold me to
the same standard that's why we do it if
you're gonna with a big Channel with
like 500k on YouTube and you're gonna
make a thumbnail that shows the Adam 22
thing and you put a title like shocking
reaction oh my God well now you're
marketing it for them imagine if I
started a company and everyone started
making shocking reaction videos you're
the one peddling and if you look at the
whole
LG TV thing that was going on in America
the way that spread was because the the
r Wing we're going look at how terrible
this is look at it it's shocking and now
you're the one normalizing it
um and I always say would you go on to a
corn website with your like Halal
audience and say look at this screenshot
of a guy banging a guy it's so terrible
you're the one showing it for views with
a clickbait and I don't like that at all
these things like the whole Afghani
Kardashian thing wouldn't have caught
any traction because women who aren't
broken don't want to do that the reason
they got traction was people and I
understand with the economy at the
moment people are struggling with money
and I get a lot of people their income
is their content creation I get that but
the the way it's being marketed at the
moment is people and it's totally
different to what we're doing now where
it's just a topic that comes up and
we're dismantling it but when you're
advertising it to get views on a YouTube
video well what happens then if a woman
and a husband who have had a Halal
relationship argue and she goes on and
she sees oh might as well just maybe I
should do that that's how it's getting
marketed and I don't like it and this
idea it's like when you look at the Adam
20 Adam 22 thing this idea and I can't
stand the red pill it really annoys me
and I actually hope in this uh podcast
that one of them gets annoyed at me
because I cannot stand them the the I
think in the current modern day the
worst thing that you can adopt and I see
it everywhere is this victim mentality
where you're a victim and if you're a
victim you put on this like cloak of
invisibility where you can do no wrong
and um a lot of people talk about a
certain group of people who are
controlling everything right and the way
they get away with it is there was an
alleged event that may this is no
affiliation with you but they're a
victim they're the Eternal victims so
when they bomb a country or whatever you
can't criticize them because you put on
this cloak where you can do whatever you
want you can't be criticized
and I can't stand it so these red pill
guys what they do and if you look at the
average life of a young girl nowadays
right well and I think I mentioned this
before they're they're sexualized prior
to uh the p word they go to school if
they leave and they're not if they leave
and they're a virgin they're ashamed
everything thrown at them is disgusting
and they comply because that's females
nature and then they get a photograph
leaked through a Snapchat they sleep
with a guy now they're pair bonding
direct they leave school and and and
make a Conley ads and then they die from
a fentanyl overdose at 40 right and this
idea that these guys on the red pill
what they'll do is they'll take a woman
and I can't stand this and I'm not white
knighting here right I don't think women
should drive but I'm not wine nighting
but if you're going to take a woman
after a night out a nightclub and you
filler full of alcohol and filler full
of drugs and then you Banger one night
and then you pull out and you do
whatever you do which is disgusting that
if you've seen animals doing it in the
wild you'd freak out
and then you don't commit and you kind
of just cry and you whinge and then you
go on a corn website when she's not
there and you watch human trafficked
molested females on the internet so you
can pleasure yourself and she leaves you
and you want to play the victim card
with that and this is what these red
pill guys do
um so as guys who aren't broken I've
seen a movie that's coming out recently
it's about um Napoleon and Napoleon's
enemies were the whole of Europe and now
these red pill guys their enemies are
what five foot two women because one of
them didn't give them a BJ in the
morning
and they always do it under the guise of
being a victim because they they treated
a woman like a hoe and she responded to
them like a hoe
um I can't stand it personally I have no
sympathy for these guys because what
they do is degenerate like if you look
at the corn situation what's worse right
because women who aren't broken don't
want to do this stuff so what's worse
um a woman who's trafficked molested and
abused when she's young and then to cope
with the pain you can then pretend you
like it so the pain goes away and she
goes and relives her trauma on a corn
scene or the guy who sits behind a
laptop and makes himself jizz to it you
know what I mean so these rad pill guys
they they're Eternal victims because
women have hurt them because they
treated them like hoes and but the way
they're not changing because they can't
admit maybe I shouldn't have just
drugged off a girl one day slept with
her and never committed that's what it
is that's the problem and these guys
will mentally masturbate their way into
end like like roller to um calling their
names now but like these guys will come
up with any justification they'll create
evil books on dating and they'll just
never get to the root of the problem
which is stop treating women like
thoughts because they're not meant to be
like that and you look in the Quran
you're We Made You in pairs Eve was made
from Adam's Rib they're there to assist
you they're not meant to be these
voyeurs for your degenerate lost because
if you treat them that way they'll just
reflect and do it worse you know what I
mean so I struggle for sympathy with
these red pill guys I think it's uh
disgusting
yeah absolutely 100 and and when if you
notice a lot of these
um a lot of these just on the first
point you mentioned a lot of these
platforms when they bring on these women
they'll end up shouting out their their
Pages where you know they they put
certain things up and a lot of them will
say that you know actually I saw a clip
from from fresh and fit one girl was
like last time I came here my numbers
went up like crazy on there and I got so
much money so I'm back here just to do
it again so they actually go on these
platforms to promote
what they're what they're putting out
there and these people that are putting
them giving these them these platforms
they're contributing towards that so I
think that that was a great point now
yeah I can't stand it I got well if you
would freshen so this is the thing they
they bring you this um they bring you
this degenerate way of life so they push
the
men should be everyone should be
disgusting and then they control the
opposition to it so it's like you know
during the the sneer van war in like the
60s there was an actual opposition that
said we shouldn't be doing this war it
was a real opposing Force to it so they
fill it full of
um hippies and druggies and they start
throwing flowers at police officers and
then as soon as you oppose the war
you're now associated with them so look
create this degenerate culture and then
they'll control the opposition to it so
a guy who doesn't want to be a will
then go to fresh and fit and watch his
stuff where it's just victim or women
are hoes or how dare you
he would never have a hijabi on
you would never have in the cabion to
talk about something good it's just fear
fear fear everything's bad everything's
bad you're a victim you're a victim
women are hoes I think like when you see
these guys with big million follower
platforms on YouTube I always ask
yourself why because if they really
didn't want you there they wouldn't have
you there you know I mean
yeah no and it makes you wonder bro like
why are they only bringing the most
degenerate drunk girls that they can
find like if the women that you're
bringing on the show struggle to name
three countries why are you giving them
a platform but instead you're
sensationalizing the fact that they can
name three countries of course they're
gonna not understand Family Values bro
yeah and it breaks it breaks the people
watching it because it's it's they see
it as their own subjective experience oh
look at all these girls you know x
amount of girls from video to video to
video they're all just
in this one specific way but I mean
that's like coming to our platform and
seeing all of our guests are amazing and
thinking wow Muslims every single Muslim
must be amazing it's just very selective
of who you bring on your platform and
that breeds a certain perspective on you
know whatever demographic you're you're
supposed to be watching It's Only Women
and literally there's literally like 11
at the table none of them can name three
countries you're gonna be like wow 11
out of 11 women can't do that in the
next video five out of five the next
seven out of seven can't wow women must
be XYZ so not only do you purport the
the false sense of reality but it makes
you susceptible now to Blackpool because
you're gonna be you know what there's no
intelligent smart feminine motherly
women left yeah yeah yeah and then it
really corrupts their ideology because
when they go out into the real world for
some reason they're unable to see okay
they're normal people are not like that
the normal woman I I meet like the
secretary of the doctor's office is not
like that my mother is not like that XYZ
at school is not like that they're just
not able to differentiate they they
literally live by that reality you know
and it's it's very toxic yes asinine
these red pill guys right and I can see
even like some networks I'm in that are
quite High ticket
like all the guys are a red pill they
always bang on about like mgtow and all
this stuff it's so gay uh sorry it's so
great it's so great
um all they talk about is women like you
go into these chats and these like red
pill communities all they talk about is
women yeah they don't they're meant to
not care
but I think it's just fear peddling
um if you create a problem you can you
can sell the solution but it's like they
would never have a hijabi on they would
never have a Nickelodeon they would
never actually promote anything good
that's why they're allowed on YouTube
yeah you know and there's always under
the guise of being a victim like
if you treat women like hoes they're
gonna get annoyed at you and like look
like you pump them full of
um what's the word
um birth control so you sterilize them
like there's a study that was done them
um men and women who move in together
before they're married have a higher
divorce rate than just getting married
and then moving in because what you're
saying subconsciously is you're saying
I'll move in with you and banging now if
you're not good enough or the woman
can't find a tall or handsome or
stronger richer guy and the guy can't
like cheat his way around and not get
caught I'll stay with you now and then
when we get older and we can't do that
I'll then settle down with you and this
is like fornication 101 it creates
resentment and if you look at how the
brain works
like the female brain and male brain is
very different so if I could break it
down the male brain is aroused
physically and mentally at the same time
this is how a woman can be just like a
bimbo and we're like oh you know curves
yeah sure
um but women can their brain and their
physical bodies stimulate it differently
this is how they can find guys like
serial killers attractive and not
understand why they can be physically
aroused but not understand the mentality
behind it
and if you look at so the way
fornication is pushed is it's like fun
and free sex and free love but what
actually happens is that you never get
to pair bond with the person
and all that happens is you get addicted
to the serotonin that's released when
you fornicate
so what happens is with these guys and
this is how the black pill festers in my
opinion it happened to me a lot where
you get with a woman you sleep with her
one night you've never you don't know
each other if you're if you're a guy and
you have a history of corn which every
guy in the modern world does because
you're just throwing it when you're
young you won't see past there are
um personality you won't see past their
values you just see them at face value
for how they look you fornicate you get
addicted to the serotonin then seven
months down the line when you're more
comfortable and you're maybe not as I
don't know as you know the the fires
died down because all you've done is
fornicate
this is how women can seem so cold when
they're not meant to be like this is
that they can just get that serotonin
from any other guy so then as soon as
they're done with you and they have that
pen up resentment of you've sterilized
me you use me for for sex you use me for
your own pleasure so they resent you to
begin with just like the start about
when men and women move in together
unmarried and then they'll just get the
serotonin from a guy at a club so if
you're going to be a guy and this is for
all the red pill guys watching this and
this is asinine that I'm having to
explain this but if you're gonna just
um use a woman and and Banger don't be
surprised if she resents you towards the
end of it and just leaves you know I
mean because they'll just use their bang
or not commit or how dare you and then
when the woman doesn't want to or
there's a guys of higher value I guess
you would say she'll just dip
but it's you doing the fornication
that's doing it no one's hurting you
these guys will talk about how women and
I like how you point this out Ramy right
these guys will talk about how women are
men's responsibilities then they'll go
they'll be like women should have a low
body count and women are men's
responsibilities and then as soon as
they're done they'll put on a unbuttoned
t-shirt leather loafers and get a
haircut and go to a club to try and get
a BJ like are they actually your
responsibility or not so so they're a
reflection of you so why don't you start
speaking about how nightclubs should be
closed instead of going there to faster
more whoredom you know so it's just all
smoke and mirrors and I have no sympathy
with these guys
um Let the dead bury the dead to a
degree because it's quite asinine yeah
absolutely and it's crazy because like
we know what would make these men happy
and it's just to correct their
understanding find a good woman be a
good man and live in a comfortable uh
long-term committed relationship that
would give the woman comfortability and
contentment the same thing with the man
but for some reason they they think
they're better off at this short-term
gratification lifestyle where they're
just get this move on get that move on
get that move on human beings need
something to do something to love
something to look forward to you can't
do really any of that stuff when all
you're doing is just like all those
things what you do what you love what
you look forward to are all short-term
everything is short term like okay
tomorrow
I'm looking forward to doing this with
her and that's it you're you're mentally
killing yourself bro I'm I just got the
monetized you know you know what it's
like as well the devil's in the details
where these guys and I think this is
where my opinion has validity because
I've obviously done this when I was
younger because you don't
you don't see any other way out and they
propagandize the idea of waiting till
marriage and genuinely you don't see it
you're blinded by sin where I would be
18 and the idea of waiting till marriage
seems like a meme to you because it's
been so propagandized by the West
um
what was I gonna say I had a good point
to make I can't remember what I was
going to say
apologies I had something important to
say I can't remember what it was all
right this is about short-term
gratification yeah so all these guys
right they'll talk about how they run
through all these women and I sit there
and I go so none of them stayed with you
so what are you like so when you go to a
basketball trial doesn't and you perform
well doesn't a coach want to sign you
after it so what do you just go on to
the court and throw the ball off the
pitch like so you get with all these
women yet none of them stayed you know
the devils are the lies are in the the
devil's in the details and they expose
themselves you know yeah so yeah I think
and this is more biblical than the Quran
sometimes I remember more from the
biologist in terms of time
well I think Jesus peace be upon him
said something like
um uh uh uh
dumb man something I'm paraphrasing of
course a dumb man built his house on
Star sand and then the winds blew and
the thunder came and the house came down
and a a wise man built his house upon a
rock and the winds blew and the thunder
came and the house stood strong and what
happens is is that this idea that women
women are meant to be these things that
just leave you and they're cold and they
just disappear as soon as there's a
better guy around it's not true your
relationship was built on resentment
consuming the other person there's a
complete there's a complete difference
between you get you meet a woman you
wait till in a Halal way and then you
create with them sexually to make more
life there's a completely different even
psychologically how the woman would feel
about that you're creating with her
that's the whole point of sexual
relationships is to create more life
there's a difference between that and
get with a woman and being sterile
fornicative and disgusting because you
know all you're doing is consuming each
other for your own pleasure and that
creates resentment and what also happens
with that if you start console if you
look at the average Western relationship
there like and I always use the analogy
it's a bit vulgar but the norm in
Western relationships and this is pushed
by Idols now the enormous you're meant
to like pull out and thingy on a woman's
whatever right have you seen Lions doing
that in the wilderness you would freak
out you know and when you do that you
now can't defend against LG TV the big
difference between a man doing sodomy
with another man and a man and woman
married creating life is that you can
create life so when you do that you're
now the exact same your degenerate
you're consumptive you're sterile you're
disgusting you now now you don't have
the upper hand on the LG TV because why
can't a guy just buy a guy why can't he
because you're doing the exact same
thing and I think this is why LG TVs
plagued the West so much if you look at
another way when when they were starting
to infect schools in the west there's a
great book about this called a billion
Wicked thoughts where they broke them
the search history of Christians in
America so all the guys in the comments
I know what you do about closed doors
right
so what would happen is these teachers
would start sexualizing people in school
but how can the father defend that when
behind closed doors he's watching school
teacher corn you can so if you want to
beat these things you have to have the
moral High ground or you won't you know
so but it's bad because then you can't
defend against LG TV and I want to say
this just before we move on to something
else right it's the watch out for word
magic I really want people to listen to
this right because I put this on my
telegram the other day is they used they
use this neuro-linguistic programming
word salad magic stuff to get you to
accept Haram
so they use Love Is Love they use
acceptance It's not love is love it's
not acceptance It's not even the gay
which means happy it's called poop sex
that's what you're promoting where
you're you eat food your body digests
the food
and excretes waste and human beings when
we used to live around the waste we
would die and what they're trying to
push on you is not love it's the ram
your thing into that it's satanic it's
the it's the inversion of the most
beautiful thing on the planet where a
man and a woman in marriage and love can
create more life it's not love is love
it's called sodomy it's called Sodom and
Gomorrah for a reason because when you
accept it your nation crumbles these
people can't procreate so what they do
is they recruit do not accept their lies
where they go love is love their little
rhetoric it's not that it's called poop
sex that's what you're actually
accepting if you look at just another
one quickly when you look at how they
convinced a woman to leave the home and
go work in a cubicle and and kill their
offspring the the what did they call it
they said my body my children and they
said
um bad you're not a bad it's
not my body my turns it's you killed
your Offspring for money that doesn't
exist to pay off debt that doesn't exist
that's actually what it is so don't call
it Lover's love don't call it my body
mind you know that's what you're doing
you murdered your Offspring to go work
for someone else who doesn't care about
you for money which isn't real to pay
off debt which isn't real that's
actually what it is in the LG TV thing
it's not love it's sodomy it's
disgusting and it should be illegal and
if it's not Sodom and Gomorrah is your
your Canary in the coal mine you can go
read that story and see how it went when
you start accepting that doesn't end
well
absolutely absolutely before we continue
so just get back to the topic and just
to add on those are amazing points um
you'll find there's a lot of strategies
above you know including what you
mentioned the whole like you know these
sayings that are supposed to
justify whatever they're promoting they
also create an issue
and then try and solve it for you we
also they also um basically like you
mentioned before create a group of
people you don't want to be and then if
you disagree with their movement they
put you in that group so you know the
names that we're gonna get called just
for saying we disagree with it morally
is is they're going to be you know XYZ
they're going to be numerous names that
they're going to throw at us but they
will always this is the red pill guys
this is the um LG TV that I'm talking
about but also the red pill guys they're
gonna call it they're gonna oh you're a
beta Center for your ear this year that
they have nothing else to fall back on
and for some reason people get power
saying these things because they're in
their Community those words have power
when your beta in their Community it's
like the worst thing in the world when
you're a simple in their Community
that's the worst thing in the world so
they actually mean the highest level of
disrespect when they say these things to
you same thing with LG TV and calling
you
open and that stuff there's there's like
a power uh level to using these words
against you and they they do it so you
can't even oppose what they believe and
last thing I want to mention
that they will create some kind of issue
like and this is not about fresh and fit
like we mentioned that I mentioned them
before but like I'm not when I talk
about right but I'm not talking about
them like I think they have good they
have bad inshallah you know we'll
discuss with it with them one day but to
move on you'll have red pill people who
will like
build this horrible world you know your
your wife's Gonna Leave You you're gonna
take the kids she's gonna take half of
your property she's gonna and it's like
yo I don't want that to happen to me yo
uh so and so red pill guy how do I save
myself you're going to want to do this
you're going to want to basically chill
that you don't care about her you're
going to want to get your money up and
basically don't give her access to your
accounts you want to get a prenup so
that she could basically you can't get
anything which that's that's a fair
point to be fair but you know they're
going to give you all these uh
prescriptive steps and points and say
always be ready and willing to leave
always have women on the side
crazy man
and then people fall for it now because
it's been ideal I I I I
idealized I don't know it's it's been
given some kind of ideology some kind of
uh perception on reality you know what
this is why polygamy is so good this is
why polygamy and the four wives thing is
so good because I have no sympathy for
these guys men used to go into war and
Khalid bin will lead shattered nine
swords on a battlefield and these guys
are making five foot tall women their
enemy and making a career out of it
are you kidding me so when Khalid Ben
Waleed was slashing swords we're against
six foot four men fighting for his his
homeland and these guys think there are
any guy who calls himself an alpha male
watch out their garments right it's
projection so these guys have made women
their enemy five foot tall women and you
call yourself a guy they're not hoes
you're a pair of wicked manner for
Wicked Woman righteous man or for
righteous woman if you're not a pair if
you don't attract these types of women
so I have no sympathy for them and you
know what these guys
um because if you look at things like
corn and you look at the LG TV agenda
the whole point of it is to drop your
birth rate and if you can't see it I
think you're blinded by sin I don't want
to come across arrogant but I need to
hammer this home I have no sympathy
um and I kind of think Let the dead bury
the dead to a degree if you look at
what's going on in France now inshallah
I'd love it to be a caliphate in five
years and I think it will because if
these guys want to sit on their high
horse and eat frogs all day and and and
and do sodomy and and other people don't
want to do that they're going to
outreach you you know what I mean
there's this victim I heard this the
other day as well where guys were
complete in fact very recently guys are
complaining about the migrant issue and
and Muslims outbreeding the West as if
they're a victim no you bought lies and
bombed other countries and they fled to
Europe then what happened is you decided
to bang an anus and they didn't
you're not a victim they kept it Halal
you're degenerate and you are a rotten
tree cannot bear good fruits and a good
tree cannot bear bad for us this victim
mentality with people is plaguing
everywhere these guys will make careers
of how to bang a hoe and then not get
caught and that's their life's Mission
and they call themselves alpha males are
you kidding me
let's let's chill with talking about
friends and stuff like this I'm I'm over
here right now bro are you
yeah yeah how is it
alhamdulillah
is it doing okay we'll keep that for an
off-camera discussion it's uh yeah we'll
talk about that off camera
with uh you know speaking badly about
these faces we don't know where where
other people might be at the moment but
I do agree
but to get back to the discussion it's
it's for like for the red pill guys I
mean think about it like this it says
it's similar in a way to what feminism
was it's like it's it's given on the
disguise of we're fighting for women's
rights we're fighting for women
um you know their basic human rights
it's a right to be to be able to xyze
that it started with voting Islam gives
that right to women then owning property
Islam gives that right to women but now
it's you know uh I can basically do
whatever I want with anyone get pregnant
and then a b o r t whenever I want in
like uh celebrate it and throw parties
and basically corrupt all these other
women to basically do the same thing and
contribute to this
um this belief that you know you don't
need to have kids you shouldn't have
kids there are hindrance in life I need
to travel the world for some reason and
then they hit 40 years old and now uh
they can't get pregnant anymore and then
just like one of the mothers of feminism
dream about having kids that they're not
able to have anymore it's it's it's
really damaging so as a man you would
say that's damaging you should avoid
that they're fear-mongering and saying
oh you need to you know fight for your
rights otherwise you know a man is going
to come and try and keep you down and
oppress you and blah blah blah just like
they did in the past so now you're
thinking I have to I need to I don't
have any other choice and then you fall
for it
as a men you would be like women don't
do that watch out blah blah as Amanda
pointed out but now you're falling for
the same exact stuff you can't commit
long term to a woman you don't even
really know how to to speak to a woman
because you're you're so worried about
anything long-term you know you think
they're not going to stay and and your
basic ideology if they're so hypergamous
as soon as a more muscular richer
stronger man who's who exudes more
masculinity than you comes around he
could just grab her by the forehead and
walk away and she's going to go with him
willy-nilly like doesn't matter that's
what your ideology you know really tells
you is that something you really want to
believe is that reality do you think
like Malcolm X's wife was gonna do that
do you think these big you know these
Great Men you would look up to their
wives would do that to them
do you think did khadisha do that to the
prophet when he was poor never no not a
chance what it is so people forget this
so with the and I don't want to be
vulgar right but like because I've had
more of like a fornicative background
just for my culture right if you've ever
like been with a woman they don't want
you like if you were halfway through and
you went right I'm gonna do you want to
go to work they'd go no so so just
before the feminism thing kicks off
because I like artistically look into
this stuff just before it kicked off
because women don't want to do that the
way they got them to do it was they
copped the men that's when they started
pushing out music where the music went
from
like simple and sound and it became I'm
the type of guy that never sticks around
and then the women were like oh my god
get this away from me so then they run
to a cubicle to get away from that and
this idea and I I have no sympathy for
for if I do if you've been misled but
guys who aren't misled and still
complain about women's promiscuia I
don't have sympathy for them right
because
if if you're a woman and you're getting
with guys and they're just trying to
like do all this disgusting stuff and
like they can't look at you in the eye
because they're so riddled with corn
addiction and then like what 40 a guy
struggle with Ed and stuff so even when
you're fornicating you would want to run
to a cubicle and then you would want to
get past around by alpha males that's a
religion like and I like you know it's
like the second coming they just they
they Carousel these alpha males because
it's a status thing they're not like
that I think it's the opposite with
women and all these hypergamy guys can
cry in the comment sections I don't care
but women when they're with a guy they
love I I've noticed the complete
opposite when you're doing it in a Halal
way and they can bond with you when
you're going through hard times they
that's that's when they see it as an
opportunity to prove to you they're the
woman you should marry so when you go
through heart attack there's a there's a
a tail in the War Room which is called
um straw pillows and it's the woman if
they actually if you do it Halal and you
pair a bond as human beings and not just
animals that ravage each other with with
no logic they will want to prove to you
during the hard times that they'll stay
with you but if you start fornicating
and doing this Haram stuff as soon as
you go they resent you they don't want
to take like how is a guy are you going
to sleep with a girl one night which all
you're saying then is I've used you for
your body and if I don't if I find
someone else I'll leave if I don't like
you well now you're a a that
hasn't been paid in seven months time
and you tell her to stop going to a club
why should she listen to you why should
she because you were perfectly fine with
her just disappearing off into the
Wilderness after using her for one night
but you don't accept that because you
see yourself as a victim and you're
putting on the cloak where you can do no
wrong and you can do as much Haram and
degeneracy as you want but you're always
a victim and it's always someone
somebody else's fault you know so even
this idea that women wait till far eh
and then they can't have kids
well I'm not being funny but like do you
also have to like I know this is vulgar
but when guys try to convince women not
to be hoes like so like I said they'll
fornicate and they'll just toss them
about and all this and then they'd have
to convince them not to be hoes I'm like
do you also have to convince her to
become aroused when you go to like do
the thing you also have the tailored
thingy to get thingy like no it just
happens and they don't want to do this
if you're not disgusting they resent you
and they rightfully should
they rightfully should let me let me ask
you this Ibrahim this being said what
would the solution be from your point of
view for broken and damaged men and
women
yeah it's hard but we get over it man
like like me and Angel are big into the
uh anti-corn thing and it's unfortunate
because that's where it really starts in
my opinion
as you take every young guy like how
many out of a million young men nowadays
prior to 15 haven't seen the most
disgusting degenerate things on the
planet when they don't understand it
what one out of a million maybe you
don't think that has any implications on
how marriage works when they're older so
what happens is these guys
when they're young they're exposed to
this stuff whether it be on their phone
or they go into their school they're
exposed to the rewires their brain to be
degenerate like a lot of these things
that is seen as normal now in sterile
Western fornication if you've seen
animals do that in the wild you would
freak out it was never a thing and now
it is the norm so it rewires these guys
brains to be degenerate disgusting and
consumptive and these women what
happened this is my opinion is that
women will have this they'll get fed
they're fairy tales and they'll say oh
I'm gonna get my Jacob from Twilight I
can't wait and then they get with a guy
and he's like can I sniff your feet and
then that's so damaging for them that
you can either deal with the pain of
that that you that all guys are like
disgusting snedophiles or you can
convince yourself you like it so the
pain goes away and then you can go
beyond oh these women that are hoes they
don't want to be that the reason they're
doing it is because if they didn't
convince themselves they like it they
would have to bear the pain of being
alone and being childless for a long
time but you get over it you get over it
stop consuming
Haram thing stop engaging in a Haram way
change your environment and you will go
back to normal you know and I'm not
saying that in a cringe soccer mom way
or like these only fans hoes will revert
to Christianity and that they're never
born again virgin like it's just garbage
but you can get over it
you know you can't I don't like the
hopelessness thing you can get over it
and I'm kind of living proof of that you
know you can't
yeah everything starts with reshaping
your perspective on reality right once
like it's like it's kind of like with
the salmon a lot of people first see it
as something heinous because that's what
they've been told and they look into it
they see it's not they can't go back to
that point where they thought Islam was
is horrible in a heinous religion they
now see the truth of it so they're like
you know that's kind of that's kind of
nice oh that's that's a bit you know
it's kind of beautiful and some people
actually like yourself end up accepting
Islam because of that so similarly when
when you change your perspective in
reality or mentality on life when it
comes to watching these things the
damage it does to you when it comes to
women in the relationship we should have
uh with with the opposite gender
you can't go back to that point where
you've got all these falsehoods about
reality so once you change that what you
know what's in your mind and how you see
the world everything else that that you
do or like you you think about is going
to be reflective on that of that
perspective so you you can't really with
a sound mind sit and watch porn and and
and you know do whatever with yourself
because there's just a lot of guilt
involved now because before maybe you
didn't see it as wrong now you do and
think about it like this back in the day
prostitute like a a term that I
shouldn't use on here I think I should
be fine so like back in the day even
though people use prostitutes
prostitution was seen as a horrible
thing it was like the lowest of the low
nowadays prostitution is like like
praised what what is it what is
prostitution it's basically selling sex
or sexual activity for money how was of
not that
what it's exact that is it exactly and
it's easier now because it's virtual and
people don't like to talk about it in
this way they act like oh it's like uh
it's more like a movie acting no it's
not
the Wonder you know none of them act
it's no one's there for the acting it's
it's literally just selling for money
and women are are being praised for
making entire careers off this like I
said they go on these shows make it full
of themselves and then have people go
pay them to watch these stuff these
horrible things it is modern day
prostitution and it's praised that's how
backwards our society is so start
framing things with the understanding
that we're not progressed we're not
actually better we are so mentally
regressed that all the basics that
everyone for the last thousand years
plus new two genders and all this stuff
we we've completely foregone all of that
that's how bad we are right now
yeah it's disgusting I people can clip
this if they want and call me a psycho
I'd have everybody involved in the corn
industry and only fans industry in jail
no no
sympathy so if you look at the corn
industry and I will continue to hammer
this away because it is so terrible
people have no idea how terrible it is
and people can go oh obsessed never stop
talking about it that's where it starts
because you make all the men degenerate
scare do you ever wonder why every guy
who's 14 walks around like
anxiety because your brain when you're
when you're telling the average age of a
corn consumer now is nine nine as a
young guy and you're seeing stuff in 20
minutes every day that Genghis Khan
wouldn't see in a thousand lifetimes you
don't think that has any effect on how
your civilization is gonna occur
um so so you you make all these guys
broken because what happens is your
brain can't tell the difference between
whether it's real or whether it's not
that's why you get Ed that's why you get
an erection in the first place when you
look at it so what's going on is you
have every single young male in the
world is molested prior to puberty
and people are not rioting in the
streets over that and if you look at how
the industry functions do you think a
normal young woman wants to be tossed
around in gang snags on camera no so
where do they get those women from it's
trafficking it's molestation when
they're young just like I said you can
either protect convince yourself you
like it or deal with the pain it's
trafficking it's
um molesting it's snedophilia I'm not
going to use the word that's how they do
it so every time you watch what that
industry does is it molests the minds of
every single man in your civilization it
works on trafficking and molesting young
women and every time you click on it
you're incentivizing the next generation
of young girls to be trafficked and
young guys to be molested should be
illegal and I would have everybody
involved in it in jail overnight no
sympathy it's completely disgusting and
the fact that people not only do they
don't care they all indulge in it like
it's normal I want everyone listening to
this to hear this and I'm not doing a
purity spiral hero because we've all
done bad things right I'm not coming at
this I'm up holier than my perspective
right every time you click on that stuff
you're incentivizing with your own free
will giving consent to enslave your sons
and your daughters don't engage
it's free for a reason do you think as
35 of all internet traffic do you think
they make a penny on that no the whole
reason is up is to break you that's the
whole point drop the birth rate it's War
it shouldn't be seen as any less
um this is why bro there was a quote by
Salud
said that if you want to corrupt the
nation make adultery and fornication in
common yeah amongst the youth yeah I've
seen that but it's not it's like that
used to be big like the nudity
fornication was back now on the scale
it's on every single young male is
exposed to the most disgusting things
every single day because they become
interested in women and then they're
just stumbling around on the internet
and they find that you go on Instagram
when people are finished watching my
live streams what pops up pause
and and people aren't nuts over this I
think what you're going to see though
because it's all fair at the end of the
day as I think you're gonna see as
you're seeing now the birth rate is
nothing and these guys that engage in it
are just gonna die off and I have no
sympathy so the way you beat these
things the way you beat the LG TV the
way you beat this this generate world is
you don't just complain what you do is
you get a wife you quit it first you get
a wife and you get a pregnant 10 times
that's how you win
you know
and that's exactly what people would do
you know a few 100 years ago even 50
years ago before any of this stuff
that's that's exactly how they were
living life the the rate in which we
have changed is is insane and that's why
I want people to reflect on everyone
just lives this reality this life so
this is all they've ever known just
imagine a society without that industry
imagine
how many better relationships we'd have
how low the divorce rate would be
compared to what it's at now how we you
know the the abort rate would be low
compared to what it is now
like it would literally be world
changing
you guys remember that um
about Balenciaga thing
yeah where everyone was spiraling and on
my old Instagram I called this out and
this is when I really started looking to
Islam because people who Gaslight you
for pointing this out I get really
suspicious will work as why do you have
a problem with it but everyone was
spiraling over the the Balenciaga thing
and they were going oh ball Balenciaga
means bottle is king So they were
talking about how they look at these
rituals like the the sacrificial rituals
they do but they do their little dance
ritual and then they sacrifice a kid to
Bow what do you think fornication is
dummy you do your little dance
fornication and then you get an
obort and you sacrifice the kid to
battle it's the same thing like this
movie that came out recently about
um
uh summed of Freedom or whatever it was
and everyone's Purity spiraling over it
as if all the guys who are calling that
out watch corn on a daily basis which is
funding trafficking and all the women
who talk about all the poor kids you
killed one for an Audi on finance that's
where it starts don't offload your
responsibility onto anyone like I really
get annoyed at this and I get quite
fired up over it because it's like the
first thing they do and you see this on
Instagram all the time and I can see it
a mile away it's the trying out the men
and women to fight that's the nuclear
bomb that goes off you split the nuclear
family like do what what's worse right
so as guys we could admit this like if
you have an empty stomach and a full
pair of bottles right as we shoot the
standard right
what's worse going into a battle against
other men who could kill you
to fight for the people you love or
convincing you the people you would have
once died for or your enemy that's what
it's War you can either kill people in
battle or just drop the birth rate
that's what it is these Red Bull guys
really need to stop drop the victim
thing you know what I mean because it's
going down a very dark path for these
people it doesn't have to be for
everyone you can still have a great
marriage nowadays and inshallah we can
all set an example for that but it's um
yeah you're not a victim and take
accountability because it can change
I remember my my teacher
Once Upon a Time he told us about like
in their society and the parallels
between their society and ours it's like
any other Society is is insane because
now we have the agenda the leaders the
people behind the scene uh like the face
of the the the nation or whatever like
the president of the king
um they have the the media and the
Layman audience so
had like a head
um Board of like directors almost and
all of them had decision making power
just he was the one person who was the
face of it all so he as Pharaoh would go
and speak kind of on all their behalf
but if he wanted to he would have off to
Musa that's what he wanted to do but
Allah Quran the people didn't let him
they said the other people on the board
they didn't let him right they said why
you know often just for saying a few
things like it's not a big deal and then
what did he do and Musa Islam came and
he made his arguments and brought his
miracles he sent magicians to go and
basically try and counter they're like
the the media the the propagators of you
know trying to make him look bad he had
his own forms of media where he would
call people and basically make
announcements and have his pep talks and
speeches and whatever
um he did what he could in the eyes of
the people trying to make him look bad
but Allah gave him Victory so the reason
I'm mentioning this is because we live
in a similar time they have media we
have media we have evidence they have or
fake evidence you know like the about
our evidence like Musa snake should
basically demolish theirs and run
through it this is the job of the
prophets and this is the job that as
Muslims we have the reason we're doing
this podcast is to to uh to dismantle
that stuff is to basically call back
at the end of the day we're not just
calling people to stop watching this and
stop doing that and start thinking like
this is to go back to stop worshiping
these things stop worshiping your
desires stop worshiping the this Dunya
and these people and just worship Allah
nothing will make you happier nothing
will make you more content you were
designed and created for that exact
purpose as Allah says and if you want to
live in a better Society this is the
same exact message that you should be
teaching people around you you should
teach to your family your wife your kids
uh and anyone you encounter and you
should exhibit these that belief through
all your actions and your speech
yeah big time and this is one for the
like you were saying there right going
back to no desires and this is one for
the guys and girls watching this who
have an ego trip if you're a woman and
you're a disrespectful
b-i-t-c-h you're not a bad b-i-t-c-h
you're not cool you're you've been
tricked and you're fed into a lie
and for the guys that think they're a g
because they finance the t-shirt and
they bought a bottle in a club and you
have work on Monday you're not a g
you've been lied to again I I had this
Epiphany
um about two weeks ago right and I know
this is like soccer mom and kind of
cringe here right but I was sitting in
my back garden and I was looking out at
like the trees and the sky and I guess I
sound a bit free here right but I was
looking at everything and I was like
this is a perfect creation and what is
the only thing that ruins it and then I
seen a bird fly over I know this is the
cringe hear me out and then it
came over me the only thing that can
ruin this perfect creation is desires
and if you look at the word desire what
does it actually mean in desire sire
means Lord d means no it means rejection
of the lord your desires are a direct
rejection of God it's exactly what they
are and those are the things that will
corrupt you so and I always say that
they're always trying to sell you these
desires under the guise of Freedom so
you're not free to buy a house like you
used to be able to you're not free to do
a lot of things that you used to be able
to but what are you free to do a woman
can kill her Offspring a guy can destroy
his mind you can get into debt these
things that they sell to you under
Freedom or things you could do in a six
foot jail cell
they're not Freedom so the chains that
are enslaving you
but again it's all free will no one puts
a gun to your head and uh makes you do
it again I I don't know how much I want
to go into this um but like there's a
question that begins with a J at the
moment there's a a quite a queue with a
J at the start that everyone talks about
um
no one's making you do it there's this
idea that people are now just blaming a
group of people for all their problems
they never came to you and put a gun to
your head and told you to leave your
wife they never came to you and put a
gun to your head and told you to kill
your kids they never forced you to take
a loan you did it to yourself so stop
blaming other people for these things
and that's that's liberating because
then if it was then that was doing it to
you and you pedestalized them to a point
where in essence they're your God now
you couldn't make a change when you
admit that you did it to yourself you
know how the Divine ability to reverse
it and and disengage so this I really
want to harm this this victim ideology
where everyone's out to get me these
groups of people did it to me no they
didn't it's all fair you did it to
yourself but that's good because you can
undo it you have the diviner but like
you're saying with YouTube and their
terms of YouTubes in their teal thingies
right you can complain but YouTuber just
made by a guy you're a guy make one you
that's why I'm making diagram because I
see on Instagram all this degeneracy so
I have the same ability they do you know
but you won't do that if you just go The
Matrix is uh tickling my feet in the
morning I don't know how dare you women
are just hoes uh no you have the same
ability they do now go make your own and
go change yourself no one's doing it to
you and that's good
absolutely I'm gonna pause for a brief
Super Chat from one rope which is Uncle
Herman Loveless you bro says keep up the
great work Brothers dope collab with
brother Ibrahim
alhamdulillah and um I think that's an
amazing point one of the most crippling
things in the world is believing you
can't do anything
I actually believe
that this is indirectly disrespectful
towards Allah for two ways one you lose
hope in the all-powerful being able to
just completely ruin all the other plans
and Destroy them
two you lose hope in the ability you
have that Allah himself gave you say
Allah not give you your mind that Allah
not give you a body did Allah not give
you any some kind of Authority or power
over someone somewhere do you really
have literally no ability to even work
towards a change because it's not about
making the change per se it's about
working towards it Allah is not going to
reward you based on the result because
even if you change the lives of millions
if you're insincere you Allah might not
even reward you for it probably one you
actually might be sinful for if you do
it for the wrong intentions depending on
you know why you do it so
Allah created you and he wants you to
work to make things better for yourself
for Allah for your community right for
the sake of Allah if you don't even
believe you could do that that is the
most crippling emasculating thing in the
world and you are more handicapped than
than someone who like their legs don't
work because at least they might be
willing to speak and to preach and to
teach people what is right and to enjoy
good and forbid evil as Allah
as soon as you believe or you feel like
you can't make a difference you can't do
anything you have lost and you've let
the to be Frank you've let the
non-muslims win and you now actually are
contributing to their falsehoods by
knowing this is one of the worst things
these are the people I don't have
sympathy for people who know the truth
who sit there and keep their mouths shut
because they're scared and they're
pathetic
those people and Allah will hold you
accountable keep that in mind
yeah and then think of it this way
um with the victim thing
um
I was going to say something I'll
remember it you're above shaitan that's
why he rebelled you're above him he
requires your consent to do things and I
always say he doesn't strike you with
lightning he doesn't drop a ball in your
head he can't just kill you he has to
make you do it to yourself and I don't
think we live in a realm where he can
just test you and test you and test you
and test you until he breaks until you
break I don't think that's how it works
I think it backfires on them when they
like the dark Forces of this world I
think when they because the hard times
create strong men I think when they when
shatan tests you
if you Rebel and you don't if you don't
comply and consent to his testing I
think it backfires on them and you get
stronger and just from everything this
idea that because the that's what the
red pill is just uh you know what the
red pill at this point is just laxatives
and these guys are all
you know
um because it's just disgusting but it's
a it's a it's a gateway to the black
pill and that's where they actually want
to get you and I wanna this idea of no
hope is the hope that it gets man and
that's why I said earlier is guys would
you have a PS wife at home and children
who loved you and brothers that you have
known all your life and you would you
would go you would have I I know look at
me now I always Roar unhappily do it
right I've gotten in the cages a few
times I'd happily do it on a battlefield
right maybe I'm just saying that but you
would do that because of the love you
have for those people because there's
hope at the end of the tunnel as guys we
just amp up the testosterone and go but
the worst part is when you make those
people
seem like your enemy because it kills
the hope and that's when you start
medicating with these Haram things I
think social media and corn is so big
now because people are medicating their
isolation with synthetic things and
that's how they get you but everything
is fair even financially I'll give you
an example of what people don't know
this because it's not told right people
talk about taxes and so do I how like in
in Sharia you don't need taxes the whole
point is to deflate the currency so the
big Fiat bubble doesn't burst right
the Amish don't pay tax because the
registered as a church and even things
like property tax in America which
should be illegal if you look at the
Constitution because you never actually
own your house it's still Fair because
the way you get around it is you make a
claim to the highest power and you can
register your land as a church or a
mosque and not pay property taxes all
fair this hopeless thing where these
fresh and fit will just roll out bimboo
after bimbo after bimbo and go oh it's
so terrible they're all hoes that's not
true there's a reason they're allowed on
these platforms this hopelessness is
what gets you because if you look at all
like look at the heroes Arc every guy
has that built-in instinct to relate to
the heroes Arc were you you're
struggling and then you get your break
and then all just it breaks down and
then you rise up as the newborn man and
you conquer your whatever it was your
conquer it's the hope that can drive you
and they always try to diminish that by
all women or thoughts they're all Gonna
Get You
you're never going to be able to do this
you're never going to do that you can
you can but it starts with stop blaming
people for your problems because then
you won't ever make a change that's
required
but yeah the Hopeless thing needs to be
washed out for because as well half the
time is that these people make you feel
hopeless so they can sell you a course
or something you know let's create a
problem and be the solution you know
what I mean yeah I never thought of a
victimhood in Blackpool like that bro by
the way on him and you don't have to
steal all the Limelight bro just feel
free to let us talk too
I will say one thing though
there's three realities
there is
the one that should be
there is the one that is and there is
the one that you
are experiencing right now and most
people nowadays they are
lost with electronics lost I hate to use
the term The Matrix but for lack of
better words it's the Matrix they're
lost in that day-to-day theme were they
can't catch the real reality they can't
catch what's actually going on and
they're only catching their own
subjective reality and their own
subjective reality is being molded by
the reality that is right now and the
reality that is right now is exactly
what you guys were talking about or you
have the corn
it's 100 free very easily available
everywhere
you have people talking about these
different isms the red pill black pill
all of this stuff
and when you start looking these things
they have
pieces right they might have some things
that are truth
but the problem is that when you do not
have an objective reality when you do
not have a set guideline the moment you
get this one piece your mind starts
turning and it starts thinking what
about this what about that and then it
will go deeper and deeper and deeper and
then ones happening is that instead of
being in reality you now are in a
delusional
stay
and this is what's happening in today's
image
you have guys that are on the red pill
and they think to themselves oh I'm
doing everything proper like I'm an
alpha male
no
you're far from it
you know yes when they spoke about
hypergamy they want something but then
everything else has started coming after
this
it's like you got you gotta be able to
realize okay what's what's real from
what's not and this is where again I
have to go back to the point that
everyone
is too caught up in The Matrix
and if we were to just take a step back
I always say take a step back but if we
if we were to live our lives
without being so caught up on
electronics
without being on Instagram on YouTube on
tick tock on all this stuff without
being in everyone else's business
if we were in our own lane if we were
doing what we had to do if we were
praying if we were meditating we were
reflecting and we were actually growing
as men as individuals
we would enter the real reality and when
you're in the real reality you can do
what you want to do and brother Ibrahim
said the best you see someone made
YouTube
so what makes you think that you can't
make something similar or something even
better you know YouTube has become right
now hey if you're watching and it is on
YouTube alhamdulillah there's a benefit
in this yeah and it's all practical too
bro you're right because a year ago
ain't nobody know what Rumble is
everything starts from something
this is the problem with the idol thing
as well and I this is one thing I
noticed really quickly was um
there's so fast things have gone that
you get that you you try things and you
sacrifice more you start a business and
one pops off and like about 15 months
ago I was working in a Potato Factory
right I know it's kind of cringe but
when I when I was driving there for like
the 12 hour shifts and the freezing I
know I said like I'm doing a little
victim thing here I'm not just for
context I would listen to like a lot of
these guys that we were talking about
about how to make money mindset all this
stuff and um what I noticed very quickly
is now that I'm in those spheres they're
no different they just know a few like
they know better marketing or they have
a better system of creating ideas
they're no different to you so this Idol
thing where you see these living men as
complete like just a Stratosphere away
it's not true and that also stops you
from just seeing something like YouTube
strikes me we're competing you know
because you are no different like Mark
Zuckerberg
who can't drink water
am I meant to be afraid as a living man
that I won't be able to create something
that's as good as Facebook you can't
drink water without appearing like an
alien like they're no different to you
um
so yeah the idol thing's a big one
because that's how they push a lot of
their stuff and I think the one to watch
out for
us suicide is for this right but I think
what might happen is they might if it's
happened or not or if it's gonna happen
how dare you is they're going to start
pushing Idols that make men sterile in
in Islam because the one thing that
Islam has now that's the only thing that
hasn't crumbled compared to other
ideologies is the birth rate the
Muhammad's been the number one name in
the UK for the past 10 years that's how
you win because again you can do a war
and Slaughter 50 million people or you
wait five generations and when the
Europeans aren't having kids and the
Muslims are what in 50 years there's
nine Muslims to one you know and I think
what they're going to try to do is
they're going to roll out idols and it's
going to be under materialism sterility
and they're going to tell young men if
you don't have a Ferrari your wife's
Gonna Leave You if you don't if you're
not some dork you owns an Ecom store
you're a peasant all that and whether
you should get a vasectomy in your 20s
yeah I've seen I've seen rule of tomasi
but uh I'm not calling anyone outright
but I've seen that anime it's just
terrible advice but the way they're
going to do it is they're going to get
guys to be like
sorry sorry Fatima I can't marry you I'm
on my Sigma mail smegma grinder set
email copywriting and I need to get the
holes in Dubai that's how they're gonna
get it I thought they're gonna get it
and they always rule out these rules of
like credit for that's how they're going
to do it and whether it's happening
that's how I think they're going to do
it so watch out for idols and things you
have your your idol already you have
your one Idol and follow what he did
because he wouldn't he didn't do that
and it's like even the hypergly thing
man I just don't I don't buy it like I
think what happens is is that when women
are broken and they're just trying to
get carrots so I think it's kind of like
uh it's like a religion where like
they're broken from a guy and they
decide I'm never getting that done to me
again so I'm gonna be a hoe and if
you're if it's like a status validation
thing you're just gonna go basketball
player rapper basketball player
businessman and hope one of them might
stay but women are only hypergamous when
they're in that situation and I'll go
back to it like the the did kadisha
leave the prophet peace be upon him when
he was purring on over there okay no
because when you're a righteous man they
want those are the times I think that
they get to prove to you that you should
stay with them and I think that's
liberating I think that's the truth you
know what I mean and I can I Can Vote
for This like I had financial difficulty
with diagram because obviously you're
making something that's up with
Instagram and stuff and I didn't take
rebar and take a loan I got some help
from people towards the end but I was
like oh I've got no money left and I
have payments to make did they that the
woman that I'm engaged to I don't want
to talk about it but like the woman that
I'm engaged to become like oh how dare
you I'm going to jail club now no
because I was never like a degenerate in
the first place and you create a
connection and I think that's their time
that they get to prove to you that
they're the one you should be with you
know so even the hype argument thing
it's all riddled with with fear chord
and marketing because then these guys
can sell you sell your dating courses
and top five alpha male ways to sniff a
girl's hair at a bar like it's just
stupid you know I mean
so yeah I want to know what Arnold
thinks about that because I I think he
yeah
that's exactly what it's gonna say so
you are you are correct they do this
because it's all money at the end of the
day they're trying to make a they're
trying to get rich quick
and you can see this because anytime you
go on a a repo YouTube they're always
trying to sell you this course always
trying to get you on the coaching or
something like this
and I mean hey it is what is you got to
make money nowadays but to make it in
this way where you're trying to alter
someone's perception and their belief
system
it's a little slimy if you ask me but in
terms of a hypergamy man if we break
that apart if we just understand what it
means it means that a woman is always
looking for the highest value man yeah
we could leave it there
that could be it and it would be
perfectly fine but when they start going
deeper into it and saying oh well she's
gonna monkey Branch you know when things
are not going so good with you she's
already looking for the next guy she's
already keeping everything open for
herself this is when we start getting
into
okay this is very questionable because
now this is this is for non-muslims
primarily you know if you have a proper
proper like you said a righteous woman
do you really think that she's gonna
monkey branch
yeah I don't think women are meant to be
like that like what's going on I I I
don't know how to explain this without
being a bit vulgar but like
oh yeah dare you right so like
I've been with women who are a virgin
before me I'll leave it at that the
before and after like if you're with a
woman who's a virgin and you're with a
woman is not the way the view things
like monkey branching is completely
different like they're nervous they're
shy they're like oh I'm meeting a guy oh
my God how dare you he's a big biceps
right and then the woman after are like
right I'm just out of line seventh guy
the night how dare you posting on my
only fans right that's completely
different so even the monkey branching
thing is when women are broken and I
think they're just trying to get out
their their trauma cycle but I think I
think I probably is kind of a Good Thing
Man like that women want guys who Excel
so I'm not like a good thing you know
because I would be annoyed if we lived
in the world where we were all
successful guys but women were still
attracted to David wood
I'd be annoyed I would like his wife
that's why we're allowed to have four
because other men are just you know I
mean you know what I'm going with this
so yeah the monkey branch and things
interesting but I again I think it's
just when when women are broken and
they're just trying to I don't know you
know I want to add that sorry on how
quickly I I don't think guys are too
different I think women have a little
bit more because they look they rely on
demand for security
um but I think men have as well like if
things aren't going immense relationship
yeah you better freaking believe he's
going to be looking at other women just
naturally thinking about like that's
just how people are in general right so
if a relationship between a man and
woman isn't going well a woman naturally
is going to start looking at other other
men which is I'm not saying is a good
thing but men will do the same thing you
think men aren't looking at like
prettier girls in life like that happens
for men as well so I think it's been
it's been outdone uh on the woman side
of things and made out to be something
it's not
yeah what I'm trying to say
is in the hypogamy aspect is that a
woman wants the best value man this
whole monkey bunch of thing I want to
throw that out because although it's
true it's true for women outside of
Islam is is for degenerate women for
women who take their desires as their
the thing that's guiding them the
guiding principle but when you look at a
righteous Pious woman
she has Allah she puts a love for us
she's a you know she follows Islam she
reads the Quran she does her best
support ego aside and even if she feels
all these things she's gonna try her
best to make the marriage work now what
I'm saying about the hypergamy thing is
that you have a woman and she wants
the highest volume in for her
now what does high value mean
it's objective
five minutes
go ahead brother
so you have a woman
who she let's say this woman in
particular she wants a man that makes a
decent amount of money now is it the
money that's actually the big thing here
that's making her want to be with a guy
no it's not the money it's the fact
that the money is bringing something
else and I was speaking about this with
someone close to me and they have said
that it's what the money is bringing in
the money is bringing comfort
it's bringing opportunity
is bringing ease of mind because you're
not always thinking about oh how we're
gonna pay this how we're gonna do this
and all this stuff that for this woman
that's value and if the man can do this
then the man is high value and for
another woman it might be that the man
is very very proper Maybe
help you mentally he's just a Powerhouse
and when she speaks to him she's always
just looking him like wow
mashallah like that's that's value to
her and then for another woman it might
be the body you know having a guy that
has just this
developed statue looking body
you see what I'm saying so this is what
hypergamy is a woman looks for a high
value man she doesn't look for a man
that's at the same value as her or lower
value than her she looks for
someone that's higher than her and this
applies to
this applies to hijabis
Chad dropped though he's in the in the
Stream for on-home dropping gems in 144p
I mean now you're looking a little bit
better bro I love him about it am I bro
is it really this bad or not but it was
a little choppy before it was it was
very choppy yeah yeah no I keep I keep
getting this thing that says low band
with like low resolution it's just Wi-Fi
I was just running with it yeah it's
just Wi-Fi but I mean there's not much I
can do I like your setup though you have
the Practical lights on the back because
I'm about it yeah
there was a super chat before from Mr
speedhouse and give uh we're gonna bring
young Don on the stream he's always
invited he knows that inshallah
um so whenever he's down he's welcome
um but back to the topic while Ibrahim
um until he comes back on DC why I
mentioned that it's like it seems like
it's the same for men because when you
describe it like that it's like oh women
have
um things that they prefer in a man
women have things that attract them uh
to a man for men the main attractor
usually is looks so there there could be
other things depending on the person so
it seems like people just have things
that they like people have preferences
and everyone's going to want to have the
best uh the highest level of whatever
they're looking for whether it's looks
or a loyalty or whatever it might be see
I would disagree though because women
this is how women look at it but for men
do you want a woman who makes more money
than you and I understand I understand
the example of the Prophet Muhammad
were Khadijah
she was she had more money than him all
right I get this I get this but in
today's lineage speak for yourself do
you want a woman who is making more
money than you do you want a woman who
is stronger than you do you want a woman
who is more intellectually capable than
you she's smarter than you do you want a
woman who is more developed in every
single aspect than you
probably not no no no no I I wouldn't
because as a leader I want to be the
most fit to lead but what I'm saying is
when you described it the way you
described it you're talking about
preferences like subjective what
hypergamy is some women want a richer
man or a stronger man or whatever man
I'm saying men might want a prettier
women a more down-to-earth woman a
deeper woman hey you know whatever it
might be and they might find a deeper
thinking woman uh somewhere else or with
another woman or they might find someone
who is shorter or prettier or more
whatever than the woman they're
currently talking to and they might be
more inclined to that woman for those
Reasons I'm saying that this is the way
the hypergamy is described uh it's kind
of like you know like how people discuss
what is a woman it's like oh whatever
they want to be it's like okay it's a
preference at the end of the day I
wouldn't just put it on to women
yeah and this is
again this is
this is not objective
in Islam you have the Quran if I tell
you something from the Quran it's
objective you can go you can look at it
yourself it's exactly what Allah they
created but this right here when you
have someone speaking uh they said
hypergamy they said so and so they said
this definition
we're just getting into different
terminologies different labeling
different ways of seeing it so it's
there's nothing that's 100 objective as
to what it is we can only really
speculate and this is why I was saying
that in in my opinion this is this is
what hypogly really is and everything
else everywhere to throw it away
because again you start getting into the
stuff that's only really applicable to
non-muslim women
this is why we got polygeny
I would be careful saying things like
this this is why or this is the reason
or right
definitely know why we have provisioning
it's not the only reason why bro
but it's because as men
sometimes things happen and Allah has
made it permissible and not General
it's big there's societal implications
with
curbing desires many men genuinely have
a desire to be poligenous and they
cannot be with one woman
and in the west that has failed the
system that is outside of Islam is no
better bro matter of fact it only
creates Xena an adultery fornication
STDs HIV you name it
there's a interesting question in the
chat here it's unrelated but I heart
Yeshua says wait I have a question says
it is perfect then how can you bring
about better verses that's the whole
question challenge that's the whole
point it's saying if you think that you
know basically this is not from God then
bring no it doesn't even say bring
better it says bring something like it
so
um if you're referring to the Ayah where
Allah says he might abrogate some verses
and bring something similar or better
than
it's it's Allah himself basically giving
people what is better for them so it's
not that you know the Quran before is
bad or something it's more it's talking
about like you can only abrogate a
prescription you know do this don't do
that or if someone does this then it
results in that
um and better better subjective you know
like what is a better car is a better
car a faster one a nicer looking one a
more efficient one on gas like what is
better I mean it's subjective
and when something is abrogated you have
to understand that it was
there was a specific reason for a
specific purpose like when the alcohol
ban came is it started little by little
if
if allow it would have just said from
the beginning
you can't drink alcohol
how many people would have just thrown a
slam to the side how many people didn't
have even given it the time of day
hmm I I would like to to slightly
different on that I actually think that
this is a misconception that people
always throw that you know Allah gave it
in stages and if Allah wanted to if
Allah will too that's you know that's
fine
but when you look at the the is in order
first
all he gives is like kind of a fact all
he says is you know there's benefit in
it and there's harm but the harm
outweighs the benefit so someone might
derive like you know what maybe I should
avoid it but that's not exactly Allah
saying that um you know start start
dialing it down and then the next one
Allah says don't pray while you're drunk
so some people might infer that oh Allah
is prohibiting a person from getting
drunk at a certain at a certain point
you know or maybe all day or something
like that but Allah is not you know
prescribing anything except just don't
pray while you're in the state of being
drunk he doesn't say being drunk is
Haram and then the last one and this is
the kicker Allah when he when he
actually forbade it the Muslims were
basically trying to make themselves
throw up in the street if they had
anything if they had alcohol recently so
it's not about doing it in stages it's
more about a person having the right
fundamental belief
so that when they find out something is
Haram they are willing to drop it right
away it's not that they're they they
dial it down till they don't do it
anymore unless it's like you know
something that's an addiction and it
needs to be done it is you're not really
different then you just you said it
differently but it's not different
because they said that Allah had
specific reason as to why he did it
yeah and the law always have specific
specific reasons and and the most wisdom
all-knowing all wise compared to
anything that we could
we could come up with ourselves bro so
when you look at stuff like the
prohibitions that were abrogated there's
wisdom in that but then you look at some
prohibitions that were never removed or
things that were never abrogated fully
like plurality for example was only
restricted to four instead of being
unlimited but it was not prohibited
completely because perhaps prohibiting
and completely will lead to more harm
than good I.E nobody following Islam and
accepting Islam
the second thing bro it's off camera but
I mean you've been working out or not
did you go to pray no I had to I'm not
gonna lie I ordered something from every
service man I come before the stream and
it was late so I just ate like a whole
cabin about five minutes there so I'm
good to go it's develop it up yeah I was
listening to what you said about the
alcohol thing and it's so true and but
when you look at a lot of like quitting
addiction and stuff there kind of has to
be an element of like know thyself to a
degree because if you get like you know
like guys when they want to stop
drinking and they want to stop doing
something they'll put on like 50 Cent
and they'll be like now is my time and
grinds it and then the next day it
overwhelms them because they go cold
turkey and they just relapse relapse
relapse relapse so there does have to be
like you know what I was watching the
other day that was so profound right
well when it comes to like the Quran and
even the Bible to a degree like it was
the previous one is that when these
normally every Court you go into there's
a Bible or a Quran sitting there and
it's like they always have to have the
truth present right and I was one
watching compilations of like these big
um Psy honest guys and when they're put
under oath of God they always tell the
truth so it's like these guys that are
satanic and the evil and all that when
they're presented with the truth they
never lie they always swear the truth on
their own they admit to everything it's
like I remember looking into how I get
the time when the Quran was passed down
that Scholars couldn't understand how
beautifully it was written and things
like that and that that was one of the
the great things about Islam is that you
read the Bible and it's just like Jesus
says one thing Paul says another a lot
with the Quran is just smooth you know
what I mean yeah
yeah absolutely and a lot of I mean are
not immersity but a lot of what Jesus
said
um allegedly you know it's very similar
Quran there's a book I know it's a
little off topic but allowed me to turn
around for a little bit it was a book
called The Five gospels by the Jesus
seminar where they looked at Mark
Matthew Luke John and then they added
multiple economists because they believe
historically it's fairly accurate
especially somewhere you have it
Gospel of Thomas
yeah yeah yeah it's very different than
the kgv isn't it yeah yeah absolutely
and so what the scholars did is they
took the gospel Thomas and the the four
um like canonical gospels and they
ranked all the verses
no worries bro they ranked all the
verses um I have them all here actually
oh yeah under the laptop we had a 54
banned books in the Bible
wow wow and that I actually do want to
ask about that afterwards because I
think that's a great topic but bro can
you imagine when the camera went down
bro Ibrahim gets exposed it's like
McDonald's and stuff
the Quran police should have a day with
that
we're going bro what the Jesus seminar
did is they ranked all the verses uh
from most likely Jesus said it to Jesus
definitely didn't say it and all the
verses that Jason most likely said were
things talking about like the rich and
the poor and basically not abandoning uh
what's good in this earth and and so on
and so forth not selling yourself uh for
like you know for nothingness and uh
talking about the kingdom of heaven and
all that stuff so a lot of the things
you most likely said are like I was
surprised when I read them I was like
this is almost exactly what the process
is about and there are even verses that
or verses from the Quran or Hadith that
you can kind of correlate to what Jesus
said and say you know these are two very
similar teachings
that was one of the big things when it
came to looking into Islam for me was
like you read the kgv and there's like a
the guy who wrote it banged animals so
why can't I write my own Bible the
Ibraham X Bible and just chat and
you know I mean it's like why can't I
just make it a red pill Manifesto
um but then I started reading like the
banned ones like the Gospel of Thomas
Matthew and they were quite Gnostic to a
degree
um but the things that Jesus said in
them is far far different than what's
put in the New Testament and things like
that and then you're sitting there and
you're going well why did the the church
institutions ban these well I think it's
got to do with their 10 percent and
their no taxes and their like you look
at I don't again too much detail but
you're looking like the Catholic church
it's kind of just like
um and when you read these banned ones
it's just like it is kind of identical
to the Quran you know I mean like when
you read like The Books of Enoch and all
that it's very similar and then just to
have it all in one place like the Quran
it's like obvious choice for me but yeah
it's a deception everywhere you know
what I mean yeah yeah 100 someone
commented um
that the 5254 banned books were like
second century forgeries but I mean this
shows how like deep the programming goes
because
there's a man-made decision to bond them
and like here's one for you guys who
wrote the Bible do you think it might
have been Rome that like killed Jesus
like you know I mean it's like it's um
it's just full of riddles and people are
like programmed to just have like a
instant response you know I was talking
about earlier how they throw you these
mantras like my body my choice uh love
is love that means nothing it's just a
way to get you to accept it there's also
the opposite side of things where you'll
say something I I don't want to get in
too much detail about this but like if
you say to someone like someone can come
at you with loads of data and I'm not
going into this if someone can come at
you with loads of data loads of analysis
that this proves everything and they say
Flat Earth and your instant response is
to go aren't there you're evil so when
you talk about like the Bible and these
things and how it's banned you've been
programmed to have a response to it it's
NLP so as soon as I you can come at them
with as much data as you want but
they're programmed to just go oh how
dare you the Trinity speaking speaking
of Earth bro what do you personally
believe
um I think it's Waters above Waters
below and I think Antarctica is a wall
around the known lands and I and how
dare you I here's one for you right I
have theories that gorg and magoger on
the other side of Antarctica
which you mean on the other side of
Antarctica well I so you know you can't
fly over Antarctica can't fly over it's
illegal it's the most guarded place in
the planet in 1946 during no 64 during
the Cold War they wrote so the one thing
every country on the planet can agree on
is you're not allowed to fly over
Antarctica you're like if you look at
the Mean Mr mustache he went that he
went over Antarctica during the second
world war so what you're fighting a two
front or who are you going to speak to
um all the islands around it or like the
Rothschild Island Queen Elizabeth Island
you can't go there and there's guys that
have went on boats and Military comes as
the most guarded place on the planet
every country agrees you're not allowed
to go the the only people that do fly
over so Bush went before 7-Eleven was an
inside job fly over who are they going
to speak to Penguins
um uh before all major political events
Christmas every year like the pope and
all the you know Jim Carrey before he
went nuts do you know where he went like
a month before he went to Antarctica and
it's the highest landmarks on the planet
you can't fly over it and it's just a
massive wall
and I think there's people on the other
side and look I'm telling you the ice
caps are melting and when you look at
the stories of gorge mat and this is the
theory but Gog and Magog are like
chopping away a wall a what and where's
the where's the highest land mass on the
Planet Antarctica is just a sheet of
wall and you look at like hidden and
plain sight stuff like Game of Thrones
where they have the wall and those weird
people on the other side
it's just a massive wall of ice so I
have theories with it but but yeah like
the UN flag is the the I would have sent
you a video after this because once you
see it you can't unsee it we know the
moon you know people say oh but the
sun's a ball and the sun's and the moons
are bolt no it's not there's demand the
you only see one side it's not
about how so is is this a ball is that
Circle a ball no it's just a circle
right you only ever see one side of the
moon I'm gonna send Jesus after because
once you see it you can't unsee it right
where if you take the Moon
you put it under like a UV lens
it's a direct reflection of the UN map
Alexandria because once you see it you
can't see it so that's where I'm sitting
with it because I think I and this is
just we're not going to go into this
right because it triggers people but I
think the whole point of like oh the
okay gravy time right the Big Bang how
do they get these lies to resonate with
you right because it's true but it's not
so the Big Bang right there's a big bang
lightning strikes primordials single
cell multi-cell fish monkey land it's
the production of a human the Big Bang
was your parents banging primarily
you'll lose lightning strike sperm and
egg single cell was your embryo or the
Egg being fertilized multi cells your
embryo the fish you're a fetus then you
come out and know you're a human so it
has I think the whole point of that is
to get people to be like well
there's no woman the red pill is true
the sun's gonna go out in 20 000 years
why not it Just creates a nihilism
because if you're in a vacuum no one can
hear your thoughts there's no Creator
and you won't get annoyed at me for
saying this but it's like the Bible says
Wars above Waters below and then people
instantly get triggered when I say this
you're programmed the whole point of it
is programming because that's just my
thesis but the fact that I can talk
about things like the fornication corn
adultery people don't care but as soon
as I bring these things up they go oh
you're crazy crazy how dare you how dare
you your program and I think the whole
point of it is to get you to sit and go
well we went to the moon in 1964 that
was a miracle
um and now we've never gone back no one
can hear you in a vacuum you're just
spinning around an infinite Blackness
why not just take that anymore that's my
theory I don't care what people think
but I'd have theories that go on my
other side right so send that video in
the group chat bro all right I got I got
a question though you said
you ever wondered why on the southern
hemisphere you can't track flight Maps
eh you ever wondered why when you're on
the southern hemisphere your compass
doesn't go south it always magnates to
the north there is no South Pole
you can be in Argentina and you don't
get the South it always stays at North
there is no measurable South Pole and
this is what I mean I can bring all this
up like three inches per mile squared
was their curvature where if you see a
boat going over the horizon it dips the
p900 camera with infinite Zoom just
debunked that so you know how dare you
people get annoyed at me but yeah this
is where I'm at and I don't care like I
don't mind I I have way more wacky
theories you know how people used to
talk about how um people used to be
bigger like they used to be Giants
we lived like thousand years of either
Adam and all that living to I can't
remember the age but people used to live
like 700 600 and we were huge and I
think what happened or how dear this is
how dare you won right if you look at um
before Noah's flawed right when you put
people in high oxygenated environments
like if you've seen the things where
they put like spiders and high
oxygenated things and they grow bigger I
think Before the Flood our sea level was
way below and we were because this is
where we go up like Everest you need an
oxygen mask because it gets so thin and
you look at like guys like Ronaldo when
they're recovering they go on a high
oxygenated tank with the red light and
they recover four times as fast their
muscles heal four times as fast I think
before the flood we were far lower down
than we are now and that's how we were
bigger because it was higher uh oxygen
density and the sun because your lower
down was more red the light was more red
so people get annoyed my whether it's
flat or not I don't know but I don't
think it's a spinning ball and I think
it's kind of preposterous once you look
into it you know what I mean but who
cares just a big wall at the end of the
day but yeah
I
I was thinking about the whole um
um huge thing yeah and what's
interesting to me is but we don't really
like know anything for sure but yeah
um there is one thing that stood out and
I'm not saying this like if this is or
isn't the case but I mean thinking about
it the the Hadith as far as I know it
mentions that they try and chip away to
the wall and it keeps kind of repairing
itself I think a lot of people including
myself which it's possible uh ascribe a
miraculous thing that Allah is repairing
like a metal wall that's possible but if
they're if they are in a super cold
place it's possible that it keeps
freezing over oh here's the material the
material mentioned is iron too yeah oh
here's the deal here's the deal yeah my
only thought was um now that they're
always talking about their ice caps
melting I'm kind of like hmm like if you
look at like another one and I know
people
so like you know when people bring up
astrology is another one where people
just go oh you're a bimbo but like and
people say it's Haram I'm not talking
about astrology in the way of I'm a
Capricorn and he's a Sagittarius you
know zodiac yeah yeah I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about it's just a
clock in the sky like it used to be we
go to bed in the sun we tell the time by
the Stars you know the Titanic thing
that happened recently was on the summer
solstice and the guy that owned the
Titanic was JP Morgan and if you look
into it it was all about the fed and the
creation of the the Fiat system the JP
Morgan who owned the FED said who owned
the Titanic said millionaires don't do
astrology billionaires do and the
Titanic submarine Thing Happened on the
the summer solstice so all these weird
little things that people instantly go
oh no
NASA told me so well I don't know but
here's here's a really interesting one
right and I'll finish on this with the
whole like
geography thing right you know with the
return of the journey I think we can
both agree all agree that there's like
loads of prophecies that are not up for
interpretation they're true and they've
come to be
you know the word sin and the word debt
used to be synonymous so it was like
um poop and sorry you know what I
mean
so sin and debt used to be the same word
and like armaic and all these things and
if you look at that that this is what I
would watch out for when it comes to
false false prophets right is if you
look at every country in the world's in
debt they're in sin every country's in
debt to someone and no one knows who the
person to watch out for and I think
you're going to see this soon with their
whole Central Bank digital scrunch
um a man who comes and relieves you of
your debt sin
that's so that's how I think we're gonna
rule out that the jail is going to rule
out you know what I mean so these things
are all interesting it keeps me occupied
but stuff to think about you know
inshallah you're really going to enjoy
the other Tuesday classes then
speak about these things I'm definitely
going to be there I've just been so
caught up with stuff you know okay so
the the jaw is gonna relieve every one
of their debt
I think so because I think sin and debt
was the same thing and where does this
bubble go you know like the bubble keeps
bursting and bursting and bursting like
they keep Printing and printing and
printing and if you look at like the
Weimar Republic or the way Fiat goes is
it either just inflates into Oblivion
and girls only fans go up to seven
billion dollars a month right and you
can buy a bag of bread for like 10
trillion right or it deflates and all
the banks go bust which is what's
happening now because you give out debt
and then you deflate the currency and
they can't pay the debt back Bank goes
bust
and I think the person who comes along
and goes everyone's in debt everyone's
blah blah dancing with the same thing if
you look at the Zhao comes back you'll
raise people from the dead relief people
with sins and that I think that's
what you should watch out for I really
think we are in the end of times I'm not
gonna lie because everything's just
flowing that way you know yeah we
definitely are in the end times the 100
to push back a bit on the the your
understanding of the job I don't know
maybe it's a it's a Catholic thing I
don't think Muslims believe the Tao is
going to forgive people of their sins
and stuff no yeah yeah yeah that's a
good point yeah no worries but what we
do know about the job is that he's going
to
is going to come he's going to do
Miracles he's going to travel the Earth
in like 40 days and he's going to work
with the Jinn to do things that
basically nobody else could do
um that you might demonically bring your
parents back from the dead and basically
they'll tell you like either worship him
or follow him or whatever and he'll use
every trick in the book up and up until
even uh like sawing a person and half
and putting them back together up until
causing the drought so people can't grow
crops and grow food and and all that
stuff
and um it will be like
nothing else we've ever seen before yeah
all right but here's a good question my
bad I want you to go bro but I really
want to ask this question I want to hear
what you guys think about this
if that time comes yeah actually is here
and he's doing these things
how would anyone be able to distinguish
if this is of this
is the
Second Coming
perfect
first thing bro first things first is
Muslims is problematic for saying if
that time comes it's when that time
comes of course okay call us from when
the time comes sorry for the uh the
difference in terminologies here I think
I think it's more so if that's the
difference in a theater
caliphates are raised and then the
Khalifa's Sons argue and then so there's
still stuff to be done like you know
where's the camera thing and stuff you
know well the reason I asked for is
because
all the prophets
they all had Miracles they all did
things which
it was incredible you know you had Musa
where he ported the sea but that was
Allah that allowed him upon the sea you
had Issa Islam who was able to walk on
water he was able to make a blind person
see again and all this stuff is like but
Allah allowed him to do these things so
now I'm asking okay well what if when
did the job comes he's doing these
things and then
people are gonna be looking at that and
how would they be able to distinguish oh
this is the daja oh this is not this is
not the job this is this is Islam second
coming or something like this I got you
I got you and this is the exact
um reason every single Prophet warned
their people about because he will do
things that no one else can and people
will fall for it because they will think
it's miraculous the prophetam gave us a
description he will have one eye that's
blind that he's blind and that's like a
floating grape and it will it'll have
the word capture on his forehead it will
literally be insanely clear so that
anyone who is a Believer anyone who has
you know uh who knows uh kind of the uh
the prophecies on it you'll be able to
see it and they'll be like okay no he is
the Antichrist not to mention it's
mentioned he's going to come first
yeah yeah the only people who will fall
for them are the people who don't care
who want to basically believe in it
people who are misguided or maybe people
who are ignorant but in that case it
would be up to the the Muslims to
basically go up and stand against them
and speak the truth and
um but most people will fall for it
because uh he'll basically be able to
provide them with anything they want
right yeah
it was the first person is the first one
he comes first before
you know what I think is the same as
well because we can all agree like the
Trinity and as a guy who is looking into
it and didn't didn't have an objective
side it's just God it just makes no
sense like genuinely it makes me feel
like a eugenicist it's not stupid right
um
what would the benefit of the Trinity be
so like it makes no logical sense and I
say a lot of times that when you when
you give shatan consent like I always
use alcohol as the example when you
drink alcohol you now want to bang a
whale and fight a seven foot tall
bouncer you wouldn't want to do that but
it's like you've given him consent to
put thoughts in your head
and I think what's happened is right
this is a cool Theory right is that the
the the the church institutions have
become so corrupt like the Catholic
church and like even the Orthodox is
just a protection racket at this point
they've become so corrupt that these
thoughts are entering their head about
the Trinity which aren't even theirs
wouldn't it be convenient if you were
the because obviously in the Bible
Trinity is never mentioned Jesus prayed
to God uh Bible's never all this stuff
oh I don't even have to explain it if
you were the digital returning wouldn't
it be convenient if the largest religion
on the planet believed that God could
take the form of man
I think it's um like up not prophecy but
a sign of the preparing of the jail
because now you already have regardless
of all the logic you give them they
believe Jesus was God even though it
makes no sense it's stupid I think it's
sort of metaphysical level whether the
agile is prepared the largest religion
on the planet at the moment or even
though it's probably going to become the
second soon that that God could take the
form of man because that makes accepting
the jail far easier you know what I mean
yeah bro we got to have you back for
part four man because we could talk to
you all day I think you're gonna you're
gonna soon become the most uh most
highest frequency T3 I'm guess but I do
have personally one question for you and
if the brothers have anything else by
all means take it away but
how do you reconcile things like for
example the sun rising from the West
which is mentioned in a Hadith a
prophecy with your understanding of the
Sun or the splitting of the Moon with
you you know your perception of what you
think the Moon is in terms of its shape
and structure yeah so I I just think oh
okay so I think you're the son I don't I
can't I can tell you what it's not right
I can tell you what I don't think is I
don't think it's a hot okay so you're
telling me it used to be that the sum
was 666 miles or Million Miles Away like
1930s and then they changed it to 30
million which is now so they're just
covering their tail right so you're
telling me in an eclipse that this is so
big bang it's all chaos right even
though we live by the laws of entropy
which is anything without the Divine
Touch of man this microphone if I leave
it long enough everything that isn't
divine
dissipates into nothing okay so the big
bang with this space garbage right how
does a human exist if we're all in chaos
in a vacuum and everything disintegrates
why do I grow hair why if I'm fasting
and not consuming anything do I continue
to grow when everything else
disintegrates is the opposite
um and I got I can't tell I can tell you
the sun isn't that what's an eclipse so
you're telling me by Chance the moon
only shows one side right very
convenient it's only one that doesn't
you can see as well so when an eclipse
one that's a billion miles away and one
that's 400 000 are the exact same size
and they're consistently it's just in my
opinion it's garbage it's mind control
to make you nihilistic and by the way if
you can rule out something like um NASA
which isn't a claim to an authority if
you read the Bible it disproves the
Bible your war is above water below's
wrong so is God wrong now this proves
your religion brings in Hedonism brings
in nihilism because you're just spinning
around
atheism right I think that's the whole
point of it why have they never gone
back to the Moon right so religion the
second coming of the Messiah is Elon
Musk shooting his rockets and they'll
blow up right and
I have a really interesting one right
and this is for Christians if Christians
get annoyed at this I'll really show are
you right now right
um your Bible was written by no one
knows who right in the Bible it's
depicted that
um if you look at God
it's like your eyes burning I think
Christianity is far more Gnostic than
you want to believe and if you read the
banned books like Matthew and Thomas
it's very Gnostic right and Jesus died
allegedly even though it makes no sense
when you look at shepherding in Israel
it makes no sense at all right
shepherding in the winter right let's
not play games now Matthew Luke and John
are very Arab names you know
um
so on the 22nd to the 25th Jesus went
into his tomb and he rose again on the
25th that's the exact winter solstice
the Son of God and the Son of God sound
very similar the sun and the sun sounds
very similar doesn't it so he died on
the winter solstice if you look at God
directly in the Bible it's like your
eyes burning
um there's a few more that I never I
never I am the light of this world ring
a bell I am the light of this world is
Christmas ever mentioned in the bible
does it sound quite Pagan to you like
Easter chasing bunnies and trying to get
eggs doesn't that not sound like a
fertility ritual it's never mentioned in
the Bible I know guys who I trust right
oh how this is a big cup of deity for
the churches right I know guys that I
trust who have guys they know who are
all into this like autistic to the Bone
right
and they will look at the Sun and it's
getting bigger and and I don't think
it's a hydrogen boss is why I buy this
it's getting bigger and flarier and
flarier and flarier and flarier and
bigger
I think this is what their global
warming thing is because obviously we
know that cows farting in petrol engines
isn't blasting the Van Allen belt right
and even if that was the case like the
sun's hitting the Earth through space
and into a VA into a an atmosphere if
you have a wave and a particle how does
a wave travel a wave needs a medium to
bind to how does the sun's wave heat
travel through a vacuum it makes no
sense right and and the sun looks like
and people get annoyed at this I think
it might happen it's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and if you
guys ever noticed and like again the Son
of God returning is Christianity wise
Christmas on the summer solstice why did
he die in the summer solstice right Son
of God Son of God okay bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and my theory is
you know they do like their sem trails
in the sky right
people don't know what that is I think
it's a protective layer if you guys
notice when you're really in heat your
phone doesn't work
you know it's like when you really warm
your phone just start glitching your
electronics stop working like if you're
in 40 degrees your phone just busts
and the and the Bible and end times
prophecy is that the Stars will fall
from the sky and I think that's a
synonym and it's like Lucifer the light
of this world
um have it now you don't need to follow
God's creation which is the sun rising
and setting you have lights in your
house the stars are falling from the sky
and now we don't have to look at the
stars or the Sun for our light we have
it everywhere let there be light right
so that so as we're becoming more and
more electronical the Son of God will
return if you look at the sun it's
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and I think
this is their global warming psyop and
they're spraying chemicals to make a
protective layer and you can you might
see this I don't know this is for the
Christians this is in your own Bible
right the Son of God returning and
you're quite Pagan sort of religion is
it that and we've had ice we've had a
flood could it be that heat comes and
and the luciferian taking what God
created and making your own and having
it now like let there be light will the
Sun get bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and take out the electrical grid
that's my theory and people get annoyed
at me for that you know what I mean so
there's loads of these different things
you know stuff like that because the ice
caps are melting but I know it's not
petrol engines in couch farting you know
what I mean it's just a theory you get
triggered if you want everyone if if
Susan if Susan from YouTube is is
watching this this is strictly for
comedic purposes only
I'm on to the mall I'm on to the mall
bro
I think um I after hearing I think there
are some things that are definitely
um accurate I think there are a few
there are a few things I I disagree
there finally some of it are in my
opinion a little bit far-fetched the
thing yeah I think you definitely are on
to is the idea of um so I think the big
bang and all that stuff plays in not
that it didn't happen
um but more so the reasoning behind it
how it happened what came before that
and all that stuff and that's what leads
to nihilism if you say gods did the Big
Bang or call you know okay the universe
from The Big Bang and all that stuff
there's no nihilism there when you say
we don't need God for the existence of
the universe that's right now and I
think there is a specific movement
behind that stuff and and the Romans
with the introduction of Christmas there
was a new testament scholar and
historian who who spoke about they
invented it but like think about this
when you say like the sun in the Sun as
far as I know I don't speak any other
languages really but they're only the
same sounding in English so when you
talk about the Son of God you know
that's going to be different in the
Arabic language in the Hebrew language
yeah yeah
because like the whole the whole um
uh Evolution thing it's um that really
makes me that makes me nihilistic as to
how stupid people are so how do women
exist how are women I think so like how
is why why do we sleep so if a single
cell multi-cell which means you can
procreate without sex so wouldn't sex
become a hindrance why did so did a
woman just have like a tiny little
clitoris once and then a guy just had
like a tiny little and then there was no
spare and eggs or how did this so they
went from not needing each other to
procreate to now they need each other to
procreate but it takes millions of years
of evolution and its survival of the
fittest so why didn't women die we never
used to sleep allegedly so how did sleep
become a thing when the guys who didn't
need to sleep just kill the guys that
slept stupid
they'll Gaslight theaters though so I'm
gonna buy a major in in like
academically and when I took
evolutionary courses they would call
these things that we believe creation
Theory
you know yeah it's like theoretical
physics like people will buy this like
big bang thing it's called theoretical
physics it's to make you nihilistic in
my opinion look these guys have their
majors in science and that you're gonna
have a not you if I had I'm talking to
like the the GOI right you're gonna have
a major and outpopulated very soon and
it doesn't really matter like all these
you know these guys are like sitting
Gaslight Islam and they were one of the
biggest reasons because when I was on
the fence and I wasn't sure
I don't mind saying this publicly you
can make a video about me I don't watch
them one of the big factors for me
realizing Islam was like the truth was
watching a David wood video and how
asininely stupid it was because I
remember I clicked on one of his videos
and he was like Islam they followed the
teachings of a man and I'm like yes the
whole point of a prop sorry a
prophet dumb harsh like it's just stupid
so are these guys that sit and just bite
an ankle bite an ankle bite an ankle
bite an ankle bite your nations are
broken and you're gonna just
disintegrate it's like the LG TV agenda
you can't get an anus pregnant so you
can sit and make all your videos all you
want you're not going to procreate so
see in 50 years I don't care you know
what I mean
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely
um and there there's a talk to the whole
like depopulation agenda and all that
stuff and then I think that has been on
the the the uprise in the last few years
um and this is the this is this this is
where it gets messy and I think this
might make people a little bit I don't
say nihilistic but a lot of people have
a defeatist mentality they'll say things
like oh the agenda's here people on top
on top I don't know about and and on top
of that when we start talking about all
these things and like whether people
want to call them conspiracies or not
whatever it gets so confusing as to what
is true what is not and this makes sense
but is it true this doesn't make sense
but it is a false you know everything
that we're hearing I think it gives way
for people to kind of just want to drop
everything and say you know Screw
everything is too much for me to handle
this is where Islam comes in because
who cares about trying to figure it out
for yourself if you have the scripture
if you have the book If Allah says
listen this is the right way to live
everything else would be wrong you don't
need to go and try and and determine
what's good and bad from them what's
true what's false from them stick to the
book stick to the Quran the Sunnah and
it makes like unbelievably easy for a
lot of people and that's why I love
Islam and come tonight here to all this
stuff my laptop's getting very hot and
I'm currently like uploading
um a file from the face Apex recording
so I think the at least I should drop we
can end it if you guys want it's cool
bro Sun's getting closer and closer I'm
telling you look it's already coming
true everyone can get annoyed you'll
wait wait and see now I'm joking but
yeah but yeah 100 just on the closing
note I would say that um and I guess
we'll wrap up because I've got to take
my bike back and everything
um
on a closing note I just think Sharia
law would fix everything like all these
deceptions couldn't happen in Sharia
because you couldn't fund them with
nothing with Monopoly money you know so
you know I think I think what's going to
be a massive breaking fact or soon is I
think one of these really cocked
countries like the F1 that eats the
frogs right
they're gonna get so disgusting and such
a low birth rate I think you're going to
see a caliphate somewhere in the next 10
years and I think once people see the I
think once you see a caliphate prop up
and people see the fruits of it and
women go oh I don't have to be an only
Fan's drug addict hole and guys are like
oh I can get a house and I can have
people around me who I like you're gonna
start to see you're already seeing it
now like it's the fastest growing
religion but I think it just takes one
little win and then everything's gonna
like snowball from there so there is
hope do not let the fear of corn get to
your head
absolutely
and that's going to come you know people
think that oh it's going to come out I
need to do anything I can just sit on my
butt and but like it you should be
working to preach Islam because it's
going to come soon
um and uh you won't be held accountable
for whether you you know you contributed
or satin did nothing
um going to come and and once it does
come you know nothing is going to be the
same as the process prophesied and I
won't go too deep into it because it's
it's a lot and I don't know if YouTube
will be willing to handle it but um just
look into everyone and tell them maybe
we could talk about it in a future
episode but with that being said any
final statements from uh you father
angel
I'm looking forward to the next one bro
Ibrahim you're always welcome you can do
it we can do it on diagram Susan
children
that be awesome and with that being said
that